hi I'm Alan sue from I'm a man i wrote
the imeem application for android when
you start the application you we give
you a series of default stations that
you can listen to but you can also
search for some of your favorite bands
one of my favorite bands is death cab
for cutie now i'm listening to the death
cab for cutie station on the station we
also present you artists that are
similar to death cab for cutie and among
other death cab for cutie songs if I
like the station I can actually choose
to favor at the station and now when I
go back death cab for cutie has been
added to my favorite station we decided
to build this application for the
Android platform because we thought the
platform was a really good fit for
existing user base we built the very
search centric user experience on the
phone around the sequel light databases
on the phone as well as the Java regular
expressions engine we used the apache
HTTP components as well as the Jason
libraries and the Java crypto frameworks
to integrate with our web services API